[Musique]
et vous
car magnifique château à découvrir nous
l'intitulé alors on a repris sa des
anciens propriétaires mais la perle du
charolais c'est vraiment à découvrir
parce que c'est un peu une petite perle
dans un écrin quand on voit tous les
jardins qui sont autour notamment le
parc ici à l'anglais se conserver et
puis on a créé une roseraie très
récemment en 2010 est donc voilà c'est
vraiment un petit bijou conservé dans
son écrin qu'est ce qui fait que ce
château vit encore trois siècles après
ac grâce aux nouveaux propriétaires
alors nouveau mais depuis 2012 un
monsieur jean louis rey milieu qui a
pris quelque part en charge ce château
qui lui l'a restaurée à son achat il
faut savoir qu'il l'a racheté qu'on veut
complètement vive et donc il a
réinstallé du mobilier qui était déjà en
place a dit gwan
il a rajouté ses collections
personnelles et également donc il permet
au public surtout de venir le visiter
ce qui rend finalement ce château vivant
ce qui lui fait garder son âme et son
occupation est lui même le propriétaire
y vit c'est sa résidence et il permet au
public de la découvrir tout au long de
l'année et à quoi ce public doit être
attentive continue château alors ça se
joue à l'architecturé vraiment l'
architecture 18e de digoine conserver
restaurer mais également aux petits
détails on voit à l'intérieur du château
pas mal d'oeuvre alors conservé ramené
également de paris on peut penser au bas
relief qui se trouve dans le vestibule
d'entrée un du sculpteur claudio on a
également une bibliothèque qui est
remarquable et puis surtout à la fin de
chaque visite un petit théâtre à
l'italienne de 1842 qui est conservé et
donc ça c'est vraiment le bijou du
château que l'on fait découvrir
c'est un château qui sert également de
lieu de tournage puisque alors je sais
pas si vous le savez mais je vous le dis
monsieur rémy news
le créateur et le producteur de
l'émission secrets d'histoire donc pour
ces émissions là on tourne encore des
petites saynètes qui sont ensuite
intégrées à l'émission ce qu'on appelle
des évocations donc là les tournages se
font enfin il n'y a pas de public
évidemment mais voilà c'est vraiment
l'anecdote de digoine c'est un lieu de
tournage
[Musique]